it's great to be joined today by Molly
McHugh who's a foreign policy and
strategy consultant and an information
warfare expert Molly for people who may
be here information warfare and think oh
we're just talking about hacking what
are we really talking about when we use
that term it's a it's a very good
question and I think it's one that's
been discussed a lot in the last few
months in the wrong way there is this
sort of focus on cyber attacks and
hacking and leaked information but
information warfare is really about
narrative and about ideas and about
putting information into a space in
order to achieve specific goals you know
for example during the early days of the
war in Ukraine the Russian invasion of
Ukraine you had these narratives about
Ukrainian Nazis and you know the
Russians needing to intervene to provide
security and that's a really good
example of information warfare where
it's it's using information to create a
pretext for other intervention and as
someone who has worked as an advisor to
mikhail saakashvili then the president
of georgia as you observe the different
allegations that were made with regard
to russian attempts to influence the
american election in november
did particulars of it strike you as
consistent with your experience and or
not consistent what was sort of general
reaction when these allegations started
flying I think for those of us that work
in the area none of this was
particularly new or surprising the
Russians have used this type of
information architecture and these type
of tactics against their opponents and
against countries that they believe they
need to weaken or influence in some way
for many years and and it's it's gotten
more advanced and their tactics are more
developed and easier to replicate
because of the internet but particularly
because of social media and the kind of
echo chambers that they've been able to
establish using Facebook and Twitter and
other
sort of media to kind of create the
impression of more support for ideas
that they are in favor of then there
really is but this is the types of
things that you saw during the u.s.
election which were the amplification of
particular narratives and stories that
were not necessarily things of
particular US interests or concern
before they became kind of social media
phenomenon it's very much the type of
very much the type of tactic and that
the Russians have used in other
countries in Georgia and Moldova and
Ukraine I'm in the Czech Republic now
they're using them in France and and
Germany as well but they do it for
specific political purposes to influence
elections in many cases or to influence
sort of social opinion or attitudes
toward Russia or toward the West but
they're getting very good at
streamlining these initiatives and
deploying them to new places in quick
fast easily replicable ways and we need
to be much smarter about how we identify
them and how we counter them talk a
little bit about that when you say when
you talk about the identification of
these techniques at what sort of
operational level do we need to be
thinking is is are we are we completely
operating at the wrong level if we're
trying to figure out which of two
American presidential candidates
Vladimir Putin would prefer be president
like is that sort of missing the plot
altogether there is a piece of this is
identifying what we refer to as just
information about facts or stories or
sort of put into space and influence how
people think that is a very specific
type of information warfare but it's the
least important of them in many ways
because it is easy to see in in some
respects what is a lie and what is true
the the more confusing part especially
for media to identify or to react to is
this idea that sometimes the information
itself does not matter it is the reason
that the information was put into a
space and a good example of that is this
leaked dossier that was passed around
from sort of out of London this former
mi6 operative had working in a private
capacity had compiled some information
about now president Trump's ties with
Russia and this is sort of an leaked to
the media
it doesn't really matter if anything in
there is true or not if it was real or
not if it was the FSB you trying to give
this guy bad information to feed into
his clients or not the point is that the
Russians want to create the appearance
that they have a deep relationship with
President Trump that they are
influencing what he does and how he acts
and that President Trump is not doing
very much to counter that counter that
idea that is really the fact that you
can see in the entire operation but it's
very hard to get past the true or not
analysis of information into the what
was the point of the action of
introducing the thing and it's it's a
different way to think it's very hard to
do but it's how we need to start
understanding how the Kremlin operates
but also how other governments and
individuals including to some extent
president Trump's administration are
violating this type of information
architecture right and that that's I
find that very interesting and I think
you wrote about this to some degree in a
great article that I recently read of
yours which is that when we talk about
when we analyze a specific obvious
untruth that is being parroted by the
Trump administration that the sort of
layer one is well what are what are the
facts of that particular story but that
there's this underlying I don't know if
I would call it a motive or sort of
reality or context where if you can get
people to just more generally be really
unsure of what they can believe as a
more general principle that that can
also play to the advantage of the
establishment or the party in power
right this idea that hey you know what
they may not believe what we're saying
but they'll question whether they can
believe anything can you talk about that
a little bit and how that can be useful
is to many to a great extent this is the
goal of the modern Kremlin backed
information warfare they're not trying
it's not the 80s anymore they're not
trying to put forward a vision or a
narrative of the world that is the
counter truth to us that is the one
thing that everyone should believe it is
very much trying to create this idea
that everyone is basically the same
we're all flawed nobody has the right to
speak or to judge or to speak truth for
anything that there is no truth it's all
just confusion and chaos and that is a
very effective way to to sort of put
forth some of these stories and
narratives and a very effective way to
counter the types of values and ideas
that the United States of America has
for many years tried to champion in the
world and you saw a great example of
that this past weekend in the interview
the president Trump was giving before
the Super Bowl there was sort of this
amazing exchange where he said if we
should if we can work with Putin on
fighting terror we absolutely should and
if we can work with the Russians to
fight Isis in the Middle East then we
absolutely should be doing that and
O'Reilly kind of countered to that but
Putin is a killer can we work with a
killer he's a killer and Trump didn't
dispute that he was a killer he just
said so are we Americans or killers too
and that's the kind of moral see that
the Kremlin echo-chamber has really
tried to create for in particular the
last 10 years but even before this idea
that no one is morally right that there
is just chaos and sort of confusion in
the world and coming through that what
you need is strength and certainty and
strong leaders and screw values and
morals and everything else what you need
is sort of strength and certainty of
leadership and that is where you have
figures like Putin and others sort of
stepping into the space offering
solutions and and outcomes that are not
democratic that are not inclusive that
do not champion tolerance but the
champion these sort of very dark
dystopian visions of the world that we
live
and what we should pursue this is sort
of inherently a question that that we
could really only speculate on at this
point but I I'm split when I observe
different events that take place under
the Trump administration some related to
Russia and some not and I go between
sort of two perspectives one is that
this is a very carefully calculated
action statement or whatever and like
the O'Reilly we're also not that great
or we're not you know we're also guilty
of some of this whatever the exact
wording was I go back and forth between
thinking it's incredibly calculated and
thinking that trumps clueless and
there's just sort of unintended
consequences that may end up benefiting
Russia or Vladimir Putin is it even
possible to clearly figure out whether
some of what's going on is calculated or
just ignorant and if you're talking and
his talking points I think it's hard to
know if they are his or if they were
presented to him by those around him as
things that he should be saying but I do
think there's tremendous calculation
behind specific aspects of the
information and narrative that he is
offering to the American people you saw
it in his inaugural address this idea of
American carnage that we live in this
terrible lawless country he's sort of
expanding this now with this new idea
that there's all these terrorist attacks
that none of us know about because our
dirty media doesn't report about it but
that the world is much more unsafe and
untrue than what we actually even know
and that is very much a tactic that you
see of sort of aspiring totalitarian
structures this idea that only I can
protect you only I see the threats to
you and I think that there's enough
coming from the President and from his
team on this topic that this to me is
the theme that runs through a lot of the
chaos that you see in the White House
yes there are all these executive orders
yes there are these sort of missteps and
false starts and
you know moving back from something but
the thing that runs through it is this
it's this idea of you know crime of
terrorism of dark forces working against
us that we can only protect ourselves
from by working with really bad guys and
walling ourselves off from the world and
only by accepting the tactics of sort of
civilian slaughter and bloodbath will we
be able to actually fight terrorism in
the way that we should be doing should
have been doing from the start this sort
of category is the centerpiece of what
they are presenting to the American
people and that is extremely worrying
because it points to a centralization of
power the belief in a security state and
the sort of structure under which they
will form these new alliances with
countries like Russia and others who are
not democratic who are not liberal and I
mean that in a small L way not in a in a
blue or red way but countries that don't
believe in the idea that individual
rights and freedoms matter in the world
that everything should be sacrificed to
the good of the state seems to often go
back to that broader reality when we do
an analysis of many different aspects of
what's going on with the Trump
administration we've been speaking with
Molly McHugh foreign policy and strategy
consultant information warfare expert
Molly really appreciate you coming on
today happy to do it thanks for having
me